would have to push sub-basement I meant
the National introduced standards of
Technology or Washington DC and I'm
going to the sub-basement
let's get dark down here we're going to
find out how they're going to redefine a
kilogram the kilogram is in trouble
since 1799 it's been defined as the mass
of a metal cylinder in a locked vault in
a basement in Paris but over the last
century careful measurements of this
international prototype kilogram and in
theory identical national standards from
around the world have shown that their
masses are diverging
the spread has grown to around 50
micrograms or 50 parts per billion and
having a standard of mass that changes
is unacceptable plus the kilogram is the
last of the base SI units to still be
defined by a physical object the metre
for example used to be defined as the
length of a platinum bar in Paris but in
1983 it was redefined as the distance
light travels in one over two nine nine
seven nine two four five eighths of a
second this definition means that the
speed of light is set to exactly two
nine nine seven nine two four five eight
point zero zero zero zero zero etc
meters per second note how this works
first you take the existing definition
say the length of that metre bar and you
measure as carefully as you can how it
relates to a physical constant of the
universe the speed of light then you set
the exact value of that constant and use
it to redefine how long a meter is I
know this might seem circular but
importantly it moves the point of truth
off of the physical object and onto the
unchanging constant of the universe so
naturally the thought is to do the same
thing with the kilogram but using which
constant and how
well there are a number of different
strategies that were attempted but the
two that achieves the greatest success
were number one using a silicon sphere
to determine and set a begad rose number
and number two to use a watt balance to
determine and set Planck's constant
I am Derrick pretty good nice to meet
you where is the watt balance the
welcomes behind these closed doors and
it's in there it's correct and right now
the problem is that we are in a crunch
to get a number by the end of May what's
the number
the plunks constant is will be measures
of ourselves in 2011 the General
Conference on weights and measures
decided that the kilogram should be
redefined based on Planck's constant but
that doesn't mean that the a begad row
approach was futile I mean you can use
Avogadro's number to calculate Planck's
constant and vice-versa so ultimately
both approaches are going to be used to
redefine Planck's constant and avocados
number simultaneously one good thing
about everything in sphere is that you
only want to redefine if you have
agreement between different numbers
right and the fission sphere method is a
method in my mind that comes out of
chemistry the image I have grabbed is
constantly constantly comes Anna can you
see this method comes of the physics the
metal prongs confident they both agree
is a pretty strong sign right because
you know chemistry and physics agree now
since I've already discussed the abogado
approach in a previous video here I want
to focus on the watt balance it's
actually now called a kibble balance in
honor of its inventor Brian kibble who
actually passed away in 2016 you know
traditional balances work by equating
the gravitational forces on objects in
two pans the kibble ballots looks kind
of similar but all of the balancing
happens on the left hand side where a
math pan is attached to a coil of wire
in a magnetic field on the right hand
side is a motor the whole apparatus is
sealed and operated in vacuum the
balance operates in two modes weighing
mode and velocity mode and both are
required to determine Planck's constant
in weighing mode a kilogram mass
standard is placed on the mass pan and
then current is passed through the coil
in the magnetic field and adjusted until
the weight of the kilogram is equal and
opposite to the electromagnetic force on
the coil the equation for this is mass
times the local gravitational
acceleration is
equal to the magnetic field times the
length of wire in the coil times the
current flowing through it
in this equation the variables that are
difficult to measure exactly are the
magnetic field strength and the length
of wire in the coil but luckily the
cable balance allows us to get around
this problem using velocity mode in
velocity mode the kilogram mass is
lifted off the mass pan and now the
motor on the other side of the balance
is used to move the coil back and forth
at constant velocity through the
magnetic field this motion induces a
voltage in the coil which is equal to
the magnetic field times the length of
wire in the coil times its velocity now
we have two equations which we can solve
for B times L and so we can set them
equal to each other and eliminate these
variables without having to know
precisely what their values are and if
we rearrange a little bit you get
voltage times current equals mass times
gravity times velocity on the left hand
side there is electrical power and on
the right hand side mechanical power and
that's why this was called the watt the
unit of power balance but how do you go
from this to Planck's constant the
number that relates a photons frequency
to its energy well it turns out there's
actually a way of measuring voltage
accurately using a macroscopic quantum
effect that involves Josephson junctions
so a Josephson junction consists of two
superconductors separated by a thin
piece of insulator now if you apply a
microwave radiation to that junction you
create a voltage across the device and
its value is precisely known to be HF
over 2 e where H is Planck's constant F
is the frequency of the radiation and E
is the charge on an electron now by
tuning that frequency and stacking as
many of these Josephson junctions as you
want in series you can create virtually
any voltage you like very very precisely
the way this is used in the cable
balance is a stack of hundreds of
thousands of Josephson junctions are put
into the circuit with the coil as it is
moved through the field and so you
exactly balance the voltage which is
induced in the coil using those
Josephson junctions so you can measure
that voltage very very accurately but
how do we measure current well it turns
out this voltage measuring method is so
good that instead of trying to measure
current directly we instead measure V on
our which is the same thing so this
current is passed through a resistor and
we measure that voltage again using
Josephson junctions and then to measure
resistance we use another macroscopic
quantum effect called the quantum Hall
effect which is beyond the scope of this
video but suffice it to say that the
resistance measurement will be an
integer fraction one over P times
Planck's constant divided by the charge
on the electron squared so if we sub all
of this into our equation and solve for
H we have that Planck's constant is
equal to four over P N squared those are
all constant numbers that we know times
the local acceleration due to gravity
times velocity divided by frequency
squared times the mass which is one
kilogram so here we have a very precise
equation for Planck's constant in terms
of the mass of one kilogram now to get
an answer that's good to say ten parts
per billion you need to know all of
these values very accurately so to
measure V for example the velocity of
the coil as it moves through the
magnetic field we use a laser
interferometer as the distance to the
coil changes the interference fringes
pass over a detector and essentially by
Counting how many fringes go past in a
certain period of time you can determine
the speed of the coil very accurately to
measure G a device called a gravity
meter was used to map out the local
acceleration due to gravity in the
balanced room before it was built in
there the gravity meter actually drops a
corner reflector down a vacuum tube and
measures its acceleration again through
interferometry counting the fringes as
they pass this is a 3d printed map of
the acceleration due to gravity in the
cable balance room the bump is due to
the mass of the powerful and very heavy
permanent magnet that's in the balance
the acceleration due to gravity must
continually be measured because it can
be affected at this level of precision
by the positions of the sun and moon and
even the water table underneath the
building in 2018 the kilogram will no
longer be defined by an object in Paris
instead it will be defined based on the
fixed value of Planck's constant which
is being finalized right now as a result
of all these measurements from the
kibble balances and silicon spheres so
right now what we do is we put the malls
in and get age out and 2018 of the
this mission a totally fix to me you
said to me less use of masks
yeah just that's just that easy yeah
just that simple simple why hey this
episode of veritasium was supported in
part by viewers like you on patreon and
by audible who is you probably know
because they're longtime supporters of
the channel our leading providers of
spoken audio information including
audiobooks original programming news
comedy and more and for viewers of this
channel they offer a free 30-day trial
just go to audible.com/veritasium you
know recently I've been traveling around
the world to Israel London Mexico City
and tomorrow I'm off to New Orleans
because I'm shooting stuff for Netflix
and what I'll be listening to on the
plane is a Steven Pinker's the better
angels of our nature this is an awesome
book that takes a scientific and
statistical approach to the question of
when is the best time to be alive as a
human and his answer is now whether it
seems like it or not violence and all
the terrible things that humans have had
to deal with has been on the decline for
centuries and if you want the
statistical proof for that you should
check out this book it is fantastic and
if you want you can download it for free
by going to audible.com/veritasium or
you can pick any other book of your
choosing for a one-month free trial so I
want to thank audible for supporting me
and I want to thank you for watching